well I love this story because it
perfectly emphasizes a point that I I've
been making for years and I love it when
I'm proven right which which you know
happens from time to time a woman by the
name of Allie ward visited a Macy's in
New York a couple days ago and she found
these gimmicky little plates that have
been that have these concentric circles
on them with the outer circle saying mom
jeans and then the next circle in says
favorite jeans and then the next circle
and so the smallest circles are skinny
jeans and the joke being that if your
food makes it out to the mom jeans
circle then you've got too much food
because you're gonna be fat so you want
to you know if you want the skinny jeans
you got to have that little circle in
the middle there obviously it's a joke
you know I don't think it's meant to be
taken all that seriously but for some
reason this was offensive for for some
inconceivable reason it's offensive to
have these circles on a plate and so
Ward tweeted a picture of the plates and
then said that she wants to have the
plates banned in all 50 states now I'm
sure the band thing was well I I would
hope the comment about having them band
was hyperbolic not meant to be taken
totally literally but the point is she
was she was upset about the plate she
didn't like the place their blood their
bad plates not good plates okay
well within four hours of that tweet
being sent out four hours just one
person one person complained and that
complaint had less than a thousand
retweets okay so it was not it was not
like this thing had gone viral or
something and 40,000 people had
retweeted it just less than a thousand
retweets just that one complaint which
that hardly anyone had noticed and
Macy's responded by saying they were
going to remove the product it only took
one complaint now on one hand it's just
plate so who cares right I you know and
I kind of understate you can understand
on one level when a company says they
get a complaint about a product and they
say all right like it's not worth the
trouble it's just
it's I don't even feel like dealing with
this so we'll just get rid of the place
you know when companies act like
pushover parents who end up with spoiled
bratty kids where they everyday just
don't feel like fighting about anything
or taking a stand ever because
everything everything in and of itself
seems too petty so you're just like yeah
oh whatever you do yeah do what you
wanna do what you now as parents we all
do that sometimes and so I understand
sometimes when companies do that where
you just you you had a long day you're
tired you don't feel like dealing with
it you know they want a snack you said
no they start crying you're like fine
just take the friggin snack take the
snack but the point is if you do that
all the time you're gonna end up with
horrible kids and when companies do that
all the time which they do now companies
are so absurdly pathologically
unreasonably risk-averse that any
complaint will bring them to their knees
and surrender and when they do that it
has the unfortunate side effect of
empowering these whiny morons who get
offended by plates and it's probably I
think there's a connection here actually
because the kids who grow up with
parents who are always saying fine
whatever you want turn into the kinds of
adults who get offended over plates and
they still get the fine whatever you
want response I mean at a certain point
just on principle someone has to stand
up and say you know I know hey whatever
I don't care what you want yeah it's
just plates who just deal with it I
don't care if you don't like the plates
you know what we're gonna sell more of
these plates we're gonna put these
circles in every plate just because you
can play it how do you like that but
here's what makes it now if it was me
and I was that at Macy's that's probably
how I would have responded which is
probably why I'm not the head of a of a
major corporation it never will be
that's probably what I would do if I got
if I get a complaint I was like okay I'm
gonna do more of that now how do you
like it now in fact our whole business
now is just going to be selling those
plates but no here's what makes it could
have done probably more reasonably is
they could have just done nothing
nothing ignore it
and you know what the consequences would
have been nothing there have been no
consequences not the slightest bit of
consequence the tweet would have got a
few more retweets people would have
complained oh the blades that'll like
them it's body shaming and within like
12 hours 24 tops everybody's moved on
nobody remembers nobody cares you just
do nothing you ignore these whiners and
nothing happens and that's the cadets
the the case with the vast majority of
complaints and outrages these days I
would say 99% of the time when a company
or a person is the target of mass
outrage 99% of the time they could
simply ignore it and nothing would
happen it won't amount to anything you
could just pretend it's not happening
people are outraged about 47 things a
day they don't have time to stay focused
on just you they've got another outrage
scheduled for two o'clock and they gotta
they don't want to be late they got to
get to it so just ignore them is you
just you in the yawn in their physics oh
oh you're upset about that okay no
apology no nothing just all right okay I
mean you could be offended that's fine
if you want to be I'm not gonna stop you
all right nothing happens do you know
how many times I have trended on Twitter
because people are mad at me about
something I said it happens all the time
okay it happens done on a monthly basis
at least and you know what it's never
mattered it's never amounted to anything
I've never apologized
I've never backtracked I've never
grovelled I honestly I'd never have even
at even when times even when times when
I tweet something and there's a huge
outrage and then I go back and I look at
it I say yeah you know maybe I I could
have met just not said that maybe but
you know what on principle I'm not gonna
apologize I'm just not going to I don't
care I mean even if I was wrong I'm not
gonna apologize because I because you
people you outraged whiners you don't
deserve to hear it if I owe an apology I
will apologize
I'll apologize into a I'll say it into a
shoebox and I'll put it up put a lid on
it and I'll just keep that apology
in the corner for myself because you
don't desert what just because you're
upset I have to apologize to you know
yeah you weren't hurt by it you're not
the you're not the hurt party now if
I've really hurt some if I have hurt a
particular person if I've done damage to
a particular person yes I should
apologize but just because you happen to
be upset about something when you're not
even really upset it's just your
performative and I'm gonna come out and
say I'd says sorry please no I don't
care no I'm not going to never that's
what companies should do I maybe have
more to say but there's a lot to talk
about today actually but before I do I
can't forget I have to mention very
important neumes you know Noom is great
because the whole task of being healthy
eating healthy staying in shape well
maybe those plates could help you
actually because but they Macy's took
them away now so now we're all gonna get
fat if not for noon because you know
that whole task can seem very
overwhelming there are so many elements
so many things it seems you have to keep
track of and and and and and so many
things you have to count and everything
and that's what it is for me when I
start thinking about okay I want to get
healthy I want to do it but then it's
just it's it seems it seems overwhelming
well noon puts it all together makes it
easy so easy that even someone like
myself can do it so imagine what if you
could use one program for all your
health and weight loss needs no more
hunting for training for training apps
workouts calorie trackers meal plans or
you gotta you know put all this stuff
together no more of that plus you know
you add a goal specialist community
members to keep you motivated
accountable and you also have a workout
partner it's all it's all kind of rolled
into one you have this all in one place
you know for me I know that my goals
partly it's just to eat better to be
healthier because I if I'm not if I'm
not on top of it if I don't have someone
holding me accountable I'm going to slip
into just the worst diet you could
possibly imagine it's a miracle that at
this point I don't waste six hundred and
fifty pounds I don't know how I don't
I'm kind of expecting one day I kind of
think that all the weight is just lodged
in my body someday somewhere and then
one
I'm gonna wake up and I'm just gonna you
know it's all gonna come out so I've
gotten lucky so far but I want to stay
healthy and that's part of what noon
goes for me especially with the other
thing is keeping your energy especially
with three kids I got fourth on the way
want to stay energetic want to have all
that energy and neumes great for that as
well NUMA is a habit changing solution
that helps users to learn to develop a
new relationship with food through
personalized courses based on psychology
Noom teaches you why you do the things
you do and our arms you with the tools
to break bad habits and replace them
with better ones
you don't have to change it all in one
day okay this is baby step type of thing
small steps make make a lot of progress
sign up for your trial today at noon n0m
dot-com / Walsh what do you have to lose
aside from all the weight visit Noom
comm / walls to start your trial today
that's Noom dot-com / Walsh the last
weight program you're ever going to need
alright just fix my collar here alright
professional operation ok I think I made
my point on the outrage thing maybe
we'll move on for that but I just I do
think that it's it's so and it's I just
wish people would understand this that
most of the time you can just ignore one
of my one thing I'll never forget I
remember the time when I tweeted
something and it people were upset about
it I don't even remember what it was but
people were outraged and but then I went
on a kind of a mini vacation and so I
didn't check my phone for three days
when I came back and I went online I saw
sort of the remnants of a past outrage
that had since passed had long since
passed you know it went on for day or
two and people moved on so the great
thing was I said this thing people were
crying about it yet I was out fishing
completely oblivious to it and I come
back and they've all moved on and so I
see it and I say oh okay alright well so
that happened it's just I think about
all these people wasting their time
being upset at you mad at you well you
just don't care
powerful you know empowering that is I
want to talk about empowering that's
empowering people are so used to when
people you know someone gets upset you
start cowering you surrender
it's actually an opportunity for you to
feel to be empowered when you have all
ever seems like everyone is so upset and
they're crying and you just don't care
you have no power over me you've none is
it your your outrage amounts to nothing
how does that feel
cry about it some more all right let me
say I don't want to I don't want to
here's a topic we talked about last
yesterday I don't want to leave it just
yet because I think it's important and
it may be a threshold kind of story
where as a society we either draw a line
finally and retreat back into some
semblance of sanity or we cross the line
across the threshold and we give
ourselves up irretrievably irrevocably
to full-fledged insanity I think this
issue is is that maybe and this is the
issue of the man who goes by the name
Jessica you Neve identifies as a woman
allegedly and I'm not even sure if I
believe actually that he I think there
are a lot of transgender people men who
identify as women and are confused they
are they have a mental illness ins of
course they're not really women but they
might actually think it because they
they suffer from a delusion I also think
inevitably you're going to have some men
who aren't even confused I mean they
know what they are they're just
pretending to be confused they're
pretending to identify something that
they don't identify as in any way shape
or form
I think potentially that's what's
happening here with Jessica you need
based on what we found out about this
gentleman so but this is the guy that's
in Canada as we're talking about
yesterday he's suing various salons in
Canada for refusing to wax his testicles
these salons only do Brazilians for
women doing it for a man is a totally
different procedure different thing
different wax different every different
equipment they don't do it for men but
he insists that they do it for him
because he claims to be a woman even
though he's not one he's trying to use
the power of the state essentially to
force their hands down his pants which
is sexual assault no matter how you
slice it and that's why this guy before
we even get into the specifics about him
we know this guy's a predator because he
is trying to legally sexually assault
women which is self-evidently ridiculous
of course nobody has a moral right to
anyone else's labor least of all do you
have the moral right to the labor of a
professional genital waxer and even less
than that do you have the right to the
labor of a professional general genital
wax or who specializes in waxing the
genitals of the opposite sex as I
mentioned yesterday the post-millennial
publication in Canada has done a been on
top of this they've they've done a deep
dive into Yaniv social media postings
and leaked text messages and chatroom
messages and so on and what they
discovered is revolting predictably so
you Nev is for one thing is a proud
bigot where he's complained about dirty
immigrants who are liars and they make
things miserable
he said that's one of the reasons he
joined a female gym is because there are
too many immigrants at the male gym now
that's kind of interesting isn't it
because he says that he's a woman and so
if you're really a woman then you don't
need to cite your anti-immigrant beliefs
as a reason to join a woman's gym you
think you would just join it because
you're a woman but no his reason at
least part of his reason is that he
wants to avoid the dirty immigrants
according to him so he clearly has
ulterior motives for joining a women's
gym which he admits to what are his
ulterior motives for wanting to be in
women's bathrooms and locker rooms well
I outlined some of this yesterday and
the post-millennial should shed some
light on it yaniv in posts and messages
has has I think made it clear with his
ulterior motives are and there's too
many for me to read them all you know
he's he's talked about he's wondered
about how many naked women he's gonna
get to see he's asked people about this
basically like how many yeah
how many breasts using a different
phrase is he gonna be able to see he's
talked about he's shown this weird
preoccupation with girls on their
periods wondering if he's ever gonna
have the chance to help a girl with her
tampon all kind of stuff like that
he he's trying to organize oh nothing I
don't think I mentioned yesterday he
showed up at a hotel where a bunch of
young girls had arrived for a beauty
pageant they're doing a beauty pageant
for young girls this dude shows up and
starts taking pictures of the girls and
this was so disturbing that the
organizer of the event a woman by the
name of Charlotte Millie Millington she
was so frightened by his behavior in his
presence that she threatened to call the
cops if he ever showed up there again
and his response to that on Twitter was
lol he laughed at her he's also trying
to set up in a an event at a local pool
for LGBTQ youths 12 and over and he
specified two things that at this event
the 12 and / children can go topless and
second that no parents will be allowed
so this is a grown man who wants to
gather with children with with half nude
children at a pool without their parents
present I mean what else do you need to
know that is just his motivations are
blatantly clear you could not be clear
about it so to put it bluntly you Nev as
a disgusting creep and a predator and
just a monstrous I well just a monster
we'll leave it there what we went over
most that yesterday here's the thing I
want to focus on today because attached
to this story I think is by far the most
egregious thing twitter has ever done
now we know about the biases of these
social media giants we know about the
things that Facebook has done twitter is
not to discriminate against
conservatives and all of that this I
think is the worst example by
far the worst example and Twitter has
not gotten nearly as much backlash over
this as they should because Twitter is
going out of its way to protect someone
who is clearly a predator and likely a
danger to children to women Megan Murphy
and Lindsay Shepard had been banned
permanently from Twitter for standing up
to this guy yaniv two women have been
shut down silenced for the sake of this
pervert it's incredible
the first was Megan Murphy now months
ago Megan Murphy back in the fall of
2018
Murphy was calling attention to the fact
that you Nev as a disgusting predatory
predatory a pervert talking about these
messages and his behavior and everything
she correctly labeled him a man while
doing so and so she was banned murphy by
the way is a feminist and she and i
probably disagree on every conceivable
issue except for this one but she is
brave enough and lucid enough to see the
truth with this transgender stuff and to
say so and so she was silenced for it
now I know this is something I've been
saying for a while that feminists
generally I mean the transgender agenda
is an intensely inherently anti-feminist
agenda everything feminists have worked
for is being undone by these men in
dresses claiming to be women some
feminists are realizing that and are
saying oh hold on a second we're really
we're gonna we're gonna just forfeit
everything we've worked for all this
time all of our arguments we're gonna
toss them out the window because a small
percentage of confused men want to wear
dresses and enter the women's were we're
really gonna give it all up for them
some feminists have said that Megan
Murphy being one of them but but the
reason why more don't say it and I think
almost all of them know the truth I mean
almost all of them feel in their in
their parts and probably say to each
other in private
how crazy this is but the reason more of
them don't say it publicly is because of
this Megan Murphy which hurt her
platform was taken from her permanently
even that is not egregious as what
happened last week Lindsey Shepard free
speech activists obviously a woman real
woman she got into a back-and-forth with
genève over all this stuff and she was
calling him out he came back by mocking
her and accusing her of having a quote
quoting from him loose vagina and and
then he said that that that he claimed
that that his he talked about he
referred to his own genitalia claiming
that female genitalia which of course he
doesn't and said that his was not loose
okay I've tried not to be graphic ID but
I I need you to understand what this guy
how disgusting this guy is and what he
actually said to this one so that was
his first comment she responds his next
response he's making fun of her for a
condition that Shepard has called a
septate or septic uterus which causes
which is its it causes a sort of a
separation here there's a it's a lining
in the uterus that kind of separates it
and it causes miscarriages and other
problems
well you Neve mocked her again in a
sexually degrading way for this
condition and said that Trump built a
wall in her uterus referring to this
condition she has so shepard responded
by saying well at least i have a uterus
you ugly fat man okay well her comments
are completely accurate he is in fact an
ugly fat men and as I said a monstrous
predatory pervert but also importantly
she is responding to sexually degrading
explicit sexist insults from a male
predator think about this he crawled he
checked every box here with this with
this comment it's ablest in that he's
making fun of her for a condition for a
disability essentially it's sexist
because he is making fun of her in a
sexually degrading way it is it's you
know harassing it's everything I mean
this is everything that Twitter says
you're not supposed to do and what
happens she gets banned permanently and
he's still on Twitter now
on Twitter but he's on Twitter
advocating for things like half-nude
swim of ents without parents for
children and himself I mean he is using
his platform to to prey on people not to
mention harass and insult women Twitter
bans the women who stand up to him
silences them and in in order to keep
this guy on I mean it's this is for the
third time I think is the worst example
of bias by Twitter it is so absolutely
indefensible
there is just no defense for this any
the most the most you could defend would
be banning both of them now I before
were up to me I would ban this predator
and I would definitely keep both of
those women around because they're
defending themselves and standing up to
a bully which they have every right to
do I mean you know honestly with this
guy with the way he's acting with the
way he's talking to women Lindsey
Shepards response to him totally
appropriate totally right like you ugly
fat man shut up you're not well you're
not one of us I'm actually a woman
you're not you poser that is exactly the
appropriate response exactly and they
were shut down
I mean Twitter has to answer for this at
least they and they haven't but they
need to provide some give give us an
explanation explain to us Twitter why
that woman is gone but this guy's
allowed to stay given the things that
he's been saying explain that to us they
couldn't possibly do it and look if you
know I I'm I'm as I said I know this
guy's a predator based simply already on
the fact that he's trying to force women
to touch his genitals by law that makes
him a predator in my book we've seen
some of his messages in her and the
harassing that he's done that makes him
a predator whether or not
he's actually done anything in the real
world illegal I don't know but I'll put
it this way I wouldn't let my children
within 50 yards of this guy and if my
daughter was in the bathroom and this
dude walked in that bathroom we're gonna
have serious problems but the point is
you know if anything ever were to happen
or does happen or has happened and
twitter has been protecting this guy and
giving him a platform and and and not
only that but shutting down people who
call attention to it I think Twitter's
put itself in not just moral hot water
but legal hot water so this is something
that I think we need to be talking about
and when we talk about bias in social
media this should be our first example
and we should continue talking about it
until at the very minimum Twitter
provides us with a justification all
right let's see Cory Booker was on was
on I even forget the guy's name
hey this guy is just so devoid of of
personality and so humorless that I
can't even read the late-night guy the
one that's I think after Fallon Seth
what does that really can't remember the
name Seth not MacFarlane no Seth not
Green that's gonna bug me anyway I mean
this guy I honestly I don't understand
how this guy has a late-night show I've
tried a few times to watch it this isn't
a political thing it's not just that he
complains about Trump all the time and
that bother
I don't care people complain about Trump
personally but he just he's never done
anything funny or said anything funny it
means there's nothing funny about this
guy and he's got a late-night show
anyway so Booker went on with this with
this Seth one of the sets and watch
watch what Booker had to say in all
seriousness insofar as we talk about
politeness which will be an interesting
thing in this campaign going forward you
talk about civic grace and you talk
about courageous empathy can you speak
- what you mean by these ideas and also
the difficulty in expressing those in
practicing those at a time where the
opponent will likely not yes look I was
running on a Iowa stage and we were so
psyched hundreds of people there I'm
about to jump up and this guy sees me
the former Titan from Stanford
University he's a big guy he puts his
arm around me and he goes dude I want
you to punch the whole troupe in the
face and I stopped in my tracks and I go
dude that's a felony man you know the
this Donald Trump is a guy who you
understand he hurts you and you in my
testosterone sometimes makes me want to
feel like punching him and which would
be bad for this elderly out of shape man
that he is why did that that's his
tactics and you don't beat a bully like
him fighting him on his tactics on his
terms using his turf he's the body shame
or he's the guy that shows tries to drag
people in the gutter and I this is a
whirl moment in America and to me what
we need from our next leader especially
after the time of moral vandalism that
we're in right now is we need a leader
that's not gonna call us to the worst of
who we are but call us to the best of
who yo Seth Meyers okay that's what I
just saw you looked it up well that was
blank so Seth Meyers on Seth Meyers now
I love that clip because it's just so
funny you see the phone enos of it where
I mean in in the span of like 60 seconds
Booker transitions from body shaming
Donald Trump by calling him elderly and
out of shape and a weak specimen I mean
if if that's not body shaming then then
body shaming doesn't exist that's body
gym so he goes from body shaming the guy
and saying he wants to punch him too
like 10 seconds later saying that Donald
Trump is the only one who body shames
that's his thing you know we're not good
it's like I want to punch him in the
face this this this
old fat man I want to punch this old fat
man to play in the face but I'm not
going to because you know he's the one
who body shames and is violent I would
never do that
how dare you body shame you old fat
miserable lump of clay that was
essentially his message and and they get
away with it of course Seth I've forgot
his name already Seth didn't call him
out on that they never get called out on
it amazing
all right let's move on to emails at a
couple good ones here I want to leave a
little time for Matt well show at
gmail.com Matt well show at gmail.com
this is from Shane hey mr. Walsh I hope
your Sunday is going is going well I saw
someone that looked exactly like you at
Mass today he had a beard glasses look
to be out six feet tall however I knew
it wasn't you because he exited mass
when the item asked he didn't go in his
car and yell into a camera for 20
minutes so that gave away the imposter
just want to let you know there's a guy
in Delaware tried to steal your identity
too so be wary with that knowledge I
hope you have a nice day
you know I get emails like this all the
time from people saying that they saw
someone who looks like me there are
these are all imposters there are people
who are clearly trying to steal my
identity and even if they just so happen
to look like me it's not intentional
they still are stealing my identity and
I think it's it it's up to them it's
their responsibility to do something to
change their appearance whether they
want to like let's say cut themselves in
a face give themselves a huge scar I
mean it's like I'm not gonna whatever
they want to do but it I think it's up
to them it's their moral responsibility
because this is not this is me I look
like this it sound like it's fair for
anyone else to look how I look you see
so I think it's up to them to do
something they cut off an arm for
instance so that you know I mean they
could they could be the one-armed Matt
it's up to them
yeah I'm not I'm just throwing out
suggestions all right this is from
Brianna says I'm a new listener to your
podcast love your sarcastic and cynical
humor
I dare you accuse me being cynical four
years ago I was a radical feminist who
believed
the Republican Party was identical to
the KKK I would have called you racist
homophobic all the phobics and basically
every horrible word in the feminist new
dictionary however during my time in
college which I know is strange my mind
changed I began questioning if I ever
had a unique thought or if I was just
repeating garbage I heard I converted to
Catholicism
my family is atheist and then became
pro-life after reading the science and
seeing that it was truly a baby I began
to question transgenderism the problem
is I feel like a fraud whenever I visit
my friends there they're all like me
four years ago they truly believed CNN
is an unbiased news source Hillary
Clinton is honest and abortion is needed
for women to get ahead somehow they knew
me before I changed and grew as a person
but I love them as friends and I have so
many memories with them
how could I come out to them as a
conservative come out to them as a
conservative I used to be I used to
behave very badly towards conservatives
and I am afraid of the backlash and
verbal assault also playing the victim
card I recently got my victim license I
am a mixed-race Mexican and Middle
Eastern women woman whose father was
refugee and mother and immigrant so you
could only imagine the array of
questions and verbal assaults that I
will get if I say anything good about
conservatism
I mean you I mean you've got some cards
there to play so that's but you know we
talked and I'm sure you've noticed as
brianna but when I talk about the the
victim cards and the victim hierarchy
the thing is it's just sort of should be
understood it goes without saying that
all of that only applies to liberals and
in fact the interesting thing is again
probably you've noticed this if you you
know someone like yourself mixed race
refugee father immigrant mother woman if
you're as a feminist as a liberal ya ton
of victim cards to play you weren't at
the top I mean you didn't say bye if you
know there are levels above you but then
when you change and you become
conservative everything kind of flips
over and you actually end up below white
men and is it on the Left you're seen as
a greater enemy even than me as a
straight white Christian male because
there's the added thing
of where you're viewed as a traitor
that's what's interesting and so um and
you know I I don't even mean to make a
joke of it because that is actually what
happens to women and to minorities who
don't follow the party line so to speak
and so I can understand why you're why
you're hesitant but what I would say is
this no I I have friends
I've always basically been a crazy
right-wing nut job but so my friends
even from back and in the old days you
know backed by friends I knew in high
school I still keep in touch with they
already knew that about me and but but
even some of those friends are some of
them very liberal in fact and we
disagree about pretty much everything
but the way I look at we still get along
and get along well I think and the way I
look at it is even as we both continue
to change and so on but the way I look
at it is is you know if if you changing
your mind about something in an
intellectually honest way even if they
disagree the fact is you've been
thinking about these issues you've come
to a different conclusion if they can't
accept that if they're gonna hate you
for that then they're not they were
never really friends to begin with it's
just they were kind of these default
people who you happen to gravitate
towards each other because you were
similar that's not really a friendship
I don't think friendships are built
solely on similarities I think
friendships are deeper than that and so
if there is so it's kind of a good test
actually that you tell them how you
actually feel you talk about it if
they're not interested in talking about
it they don't want to be around you
don't want to see you they reject you
then that's a good testing you see that
there was never that deeper thing that
actual real friendship that that bond
was bonding you together and so you're
not losing much now I know that's not
much of a solace not much consolation
when you're losing people who you've
known a long time and you're you know
your whole life is sort of shifting and
all of that it's not much consolation
but it is true at least you know that
that if you do lose friends over it you
didn't really lose friends because they
weren't to begin with
but I congratulate your courage and and
also your just intellectual honesty to
actually think about these issues and
and be willing to change your mind I
have so much respect for people that can
do that because so many other people on
both sides are unwilling will not do it
can't do it will never do it and so the
fact that you do and have and will is I
think really great all right this is
from Daniel big fan of the show you
recently did a mailbag segment and
answer to question about the ontological
argument for the existence of God you
answered that existence is not a
predicate and therefore renders the
argument invalid I would like to offer a
rebuttal to this although it is accurate
to say that the existence that existence
is not a predicate that doesn't actually
affect the argument because the thing in
question is not merely existence but
necessary existence in attribute that
only a maximally great being could
possess as such a few implications
follow these implications which when
stated as premises in a syllogism form
the current iteration of the argument it
is just it just so happens that st.
Anselm's version has been supplanted by
Alvin Plantinga and is constructed as
follow follows one God is by definition
the greatest conceivable being to if
such a maximally great being is even
possible
then it exists in some possible world 3
if it exists in some possible world then
it exists in every possible world by the
necessity of its own nature for if it
exists in every possible world that it
exists in the actual world 5 if it
exists in the actual world then it
exists 6 therefore God exists I know you
think it sounds like a too good to be
true argument by the way you so
cavalierly dismiss it as an attempt to
conjure God in a word game quote unquote
but the premises are purely deductive
they follow from each from each other
and escape ibly and no atheist has ever
been able to refute them for example
William Lane Craig has been using the
argument for decades and even his most
formidable opponents seem to only be
able to dismiss it in the same manner
without actually addressing any of the
premises alright um you know I've gotten
a lot of email about the ontological
argument I didn't realize it's it's so
popular I I so that's been news to me
that's been interesting apparently this
is a popular argument a lot of
Christians like
I still don't I don't think I apparently
didn't do a very good job of explaining
why I don't like it let me try again
obviously he goes without saying I agree
with the conclusion number six therefore
God exists I agree with that part but I
don't think the argument works I don't
think the argument gets you there I
don't think the argument proves the
conclusion and I'll try to explain why
now obviously if I can prove that there
are problems with any of your premises
then I've proven that the argument as
constructed is invalid I mean obviously
your conclusion flows from the premises
if the premises don't work then the
conclusion is is then the argument is
invalid even if the conclusion is
ultimately correct so let's go through
this first premise God is by definition
the greatest conceivable being we
already have a problem I I think you've
got a problem there I think we could
stop right there really because is that
the definition of God I mean that's your
definition that's my definition
I believe that's what God is but there
are other plausible and logical
definitions of God so in order for this
arguments work you are assuming a
definition of God that works for your
argument but that's not the only
definition you need everyone to just
accept that definition for the argument
to work but first you have yet but you
have to prove it first and you haven't
done that you've got a whole other
argument you have to make to prove that
God is the greatest conceivable being
which is a problem because you're trying
to prove the definition of something
that you haven't yet proven exists in
the first place yet you need it to be
defined in order to prove that it exists
and so you have a circular argument you
have the you're going in circles here
there are plausible logical possible
definitions of God that do not include
things like omniscience omnipotence
perfect morality you know all good all
loving and so on there are plausible
possible definitions of God that don't
include those things in fact it is
plausible though I don't believe this
or I should say possible it is possible
that God is inferior to his creation in
certain ways that is a possible
definition
now when I say possible I think you know
that I say possible in this in straight
and a strictly philosophical sense I say
possible in the same way that I would
say it's possible that unicorns exist
they don't exist but it's possible it's
not logically impossible so that's what
in a philosophical sense just to clarify
for anyone who's confused when I say
it's possible that God is inferior
God is not all-powerful so I'm not
saying that I believe that or that I
think it's likely or anything I'm just
saying that it's it's not logically
impossible
so a God who is not all-powerful is not
the same as an unmarried bachelor an
unmarried bachelor is logically
impossible a God who is limited in his
power is not logically impossible
maybe the deists are right and God is a
force that just got the ball rolling and
then sat back and does nothing no I mean
maybe God got the ball rolling and then
disappeared and doesn't exist anymore I
mean in that case he's not omniscient
not omnipotent doesn't need to be
certainly doesn't need to be all loving
probably isn't if the DSR right there
could in that case be beings in the
universe who are more loving more
knowledgeable than God possibly even
more powerful than God I mean the Oh in
order for at the most basic definition
the only thing God needs to be able to
do is get the ball rolling on the
universe it's it's he doesn't need to
have any other powers aside from that
maybe the Greeks were right and God is
is a pretty powerful being but he's also
Petty and jealous and kind of stupid
sometimes and not all-knowing in which
case you know you could argue that a
virtuous human being is greater than God
at least in some sense maybe the
pantheists are right and God is just a
force like like love you know an
abstraction I don't believe any of that
but I think your argument fails because
you've ruled out those possibilities to
begin with without proving that they
should be ruled out
premise two you say if such a maximally
great being is even possible then it
exists in some possible world the
problem is that you haven't defined
exists okay does love exists it it
doesn't exist as a thing it isn't a
person it's an it's a sort of an
abstract concept it's a force okay
what if love is God what if the universe
is bound together by the energy of love
or some such crap something like that I
mean some something that some new-age
[ __ ] would say it's not it's not that
logically impossible premise three you
say if it exists in some possible world
then it exists in every possible world
by the necessity of its own nature we
got a big problem here I don't see how
you've proven that God is necessary by
his nature just because he's a
conceivable being who is perfectly great
though not necessarily perfectly great
as I've established I don't see how that
proves that he's necessary I think
you've just kind of snuck that into the
premise without proving it I mean I
think if an atheist well atheists I
think you could stop you right there and
say why is he necessary what do you mean
just because he's even if I accept that
God by definition as great as possible
big that doesn't make him necessary
doesn't make him necessary for reality
to exist the premise is an assertion
that also needs to be proven unless your
defining greatness in part as necessity
you know a perfectly great being has to
also be necessary for reality but that's
special pleading
you're just you're putting your argument
into the definition it seems like you're
doing that all over the place with all
these premises you're you're just
supplanting assumptions from your
conclusion into all of these arguments
which you can't do it's not it's not
valid sound a valid way of arguing so it
seems for this argument to work you've
assumed you've asserted from the get-go
without proving it that God is both
maximally great and necessary circular I
think now I see what you've done here or
or what planting has done
you've subbed out the whole bit about
how God's greatness means you know he
must exist because it's greater to exist
that not exist that that was an Psalms
formulation which is what I responded to
so you've gotten rid of that but instead
you in a said you said well he's
necessary by his nature but again you
haven't proved that he's necessary by
his nature you've dropped it into the
premise without proving it so I think
you need to stick with the assertion
with an cells assertion that a great
being must exist because it's greater to
exist and not exist and that's where you
get the necessity from but that doesn't
work because it does treat existence as
a feature as a trait and it assumes that
existence is necessarily greater than
non-existence which it probably is but I
you know you've got to define the word
great which you haven't done and I mean
it at a minimum before you begin this
argument you've got a what do you mean
by great I mean is it possible for
something that doesn't exist to be
greater than something that does I I
mean I don't know I you could
potentially make that argument and that
argument also doesn't work because
because of because it can be used to
prove the existence of literally
anything let me show you what I mean
using most of your argument only taking
out the necessity bit and putting in an
cells formulation because I think that's
the only way this works so but but but
it doesn't work because of this premise
one a superhuman basketball player is by
definition the greatest conceivable
basketball player he can for instance
hit every shot he's got a 100% shooting
percentage I think we could all agree
that a the greatest conceivable
basketball player at a minimum can hit
every shot to if such a maximally great
basketball player is even possible then
it exists in some possible world and it
is possible it's not logically
impossible that you could have a guy
that hits every single shot even from a
hundred miles away it's not logically
impossible three if it exists in some
possible world then it exists in every
possible world because it is greater to
exist than not exist plus you can't
really hit a jump shot if you don't
exist number four if it exists in every
possible world then it exists in the
actual world five if it exists in the
actual world then it exists six
therefore the NBA better go find this
guy you know because he's so far gone
undrafted is that a reductio ad absurdum
argument well you're absolutely right of
course it is and
and that's a problem you know if I can
use your argument in tact to prove
things that we all know are not true
like for instance that a basketball
player with a hundred percent shooting
percentage exists that means your
argument is flawed it doesn't mean your
conclusions fly it means your argument
the way you got there is flawed and I
mean you could sub in any really
anything you can use this argument to
prove anything unless again you're
setting the argument up in such a
specific way that it could only possibly
apply to God and that it that you're
setting it up so that this form of
argumentation is invalid when applied in
any other circumstance but that is
special pleading you're setting up the
argument specially so that it only will
prove your conclusion there's one last
problem here that I'll mention just
that's kind of a warning okay if you're
gonna try this against a atheist here's
another thing that's going to happen
even if they let you get away with the
whole bit and premise one where you're
saying God is maximally great by
definition he's all-knowing is all you
know is omniscient omnipotent all good
all you know all of that let's say they
accept them well there the next step if
they're smart is they're gonna say well
hold on a second because then you go for
premise two and you say that if such a
being is even possible it exists in some
possible world what they're gonna say is
well that being is not possible actually
that's an impossible being not not that
that you know there could be some
version of a god that's possible but
that particular version that you're
using here is not possible because it's
a logical contradiction and what they'll
say is that omniscience and omnipotence
are logically contradictory because if a
being knows everything if he's
omniscient that he knows what he's going
to do in the future
if he's omnipotent that he can do
anything but if he's omniscient he knows
he's gonna do in the future which means
he can't not do the thing he knew he was
going to do which means he's not
omnipotent and if he can really do
anything and make any choice at end
moment than he's not on mission now that
to me that argument obviously I Mathias
oh I don't think that argument disproves
God it is an interesting argument it's
an argument you better have an answer
for and a good one because you're
walking right into that now you know I I
think we're getting into areas where
it's just beyond our comprehension as
human beings but you can't see as a
thing but that's my believe it I think
it's beyond our comprehension you can't
do that if you're trying to make a
logical argument if you're trying to put
you play this game on a philosophical
level and an atheist comes back with
something like that you can't say well
yeah it's but it's beyond our
comprehension you can't do that you
can't just say well this parts your
objections are beyond our comprehension
let's move forward with my logical
argument you can't do that so you better
have an answer maybe you haven't it's I
don't you know I'm I've thought about
that question a lot I don't exact now I
think the answer you might go with is
you might say well he's outside of time
and space so there is no going to do you
know God is all now all action all
present there is no it's not like he's
looking into the future and knows what
he's going to do then the problem is
that you have just said that God exists
outside of time in space and so the next
question is going to be well if
something is outside of time-space by
definition it doesn't exist you know
provide a definition of existence that
could include the possibility of not
being in time or space and that's going
to be a difficult challenge as well so
which again I think you could do but you
better have an answer for it a good one
if you want this to work so there's a
lot of stuff you got to sort through
before you can even get to this argument
and I think once you've got gotten there
you still have problems and that's why I
just don't think it works I I think it's
the kind of theistic argument if I could
say so that is impressive to theists we
like it because it sounds smart but I
don't think you're gonna find many
atheist who are impressed by it and
ultimately if you're making a logical
argument for God then who you're making
it for I mean you're not making it for
yourself right unless you're trying to
convince yourself you're making it for
people
so you know it's got to be compelling to
them and for all the reasons I've
stipulated I don't think it is alright
that was a very long discussion of that
we will leave it there thanks everybody
for watching Godspeed a man sues
immigrant women for refusing to wax his
genitals miss world USA dethrones miss
Michigan for refusing to wear a hijab
and three Democratic presidential
candidates choose their preferred
pronouns all that and more check it out
on the Michael Knowles show